hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast the micro RNA regulatory
landscape of MSC derive exosomes a
system view presented by julian Nuland
assistant professor Department of
pharmaceutical Sciences School of
Pharmacy and Pharmaceutical Sciences
University of Buffalo I'm Alexis Krause
labyrinth and Alber moderator for
today's event we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by laborat and sponsored by
nano string technologies for more
information about our sponsor please
visit w-w-w want at any time you want
during the presentation just click on
the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen and type your
questions into the drop-down box that
appears on the screen
well answer as many of your questions as
we have time for at the end of the
presentation if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation please click
on the help desk button located in the
promotional ward at the bottom center of
your screen or use the ask a question
box to let us know that you're having a
problem this presentation is educational
and thus offers continuing education
credits please click on the continuing
education credits tab located in the top
right corner of the presentation window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits please join me in welcoming dr.
nuit I will now turn the presentation
over to her
Thank You Alexis for the introduction
thank you for having me here today so
I'm going to talk about our work on
excellent characterization and exosomes
as drug carriers in the last few years
there has been great interest in
exosomes and the role in intercellular
communication systems exert specific
effects on the micro environment and in
doing so play important roles and
intercellular communication in both
healthy and diseased tissues so in this
image you can see how exosomes are
secreted by doing ourselves and are then
taken up by the recipient cells and so
exosomes are able to functionally
transfer micro rna's non-coding rnas
proteins but also lipids into the
recipient cells and in doing so exert
specific biological effects on the
recipient cell many groups have started
to use exosomes
as delivery vehicles for different types
of cargos as you can see here on this
table this one specifically focuses on
the delivery of our a pre micro RNA and
si RNA the applications arranged from
neurological diseases to cancer and
tissue regeneration including ischemic
heart diseases and brain diseases and
what you can also see from this table is
that different types of cells are used
as donors for exercise popular cells are
human embryonic kidney cells your
abbreviated as tag to 9 suite T cells
mesenchymal stem cells but also cancer
cell yet so despite
progress and the great interest in
exosome base therapeutics they are still
challenges associated with using
exosomes as drug carriers as you can see
here exosomes contain a lot of different
components mRNA non-coding RNA they can
contain proteins in the lipid membrane
and they can also contain proteins in
the hydrophilic core of the exosomes and
they are consists of lipid bilayer there
were so many components it's really
important to ask what is the function of
all these components and how do they
affect the intrinsic biological effects
of the exercise and this is important
for two reasons the first reason is can
we capitalize on the intrinsic
biological effects of exercise as strong
carriers and the second question is how
do these different components affect the
side effects of exercise when used as
struck carriers
and so one of the exosomes we are
interested in where exosomes derive from
mesenchymal stem cells
so mesenchymal sample exosomes of
interest because of their ability to
regenerate tissues after myocardial
infarction but also after impacts of the
brain and the ability to promote wound
healing over the last few years
researchers have discovered that part of
the regenerative effects of MSDS is
mediated by exercise and this was a very
important finding as it would open up
new avenues for cell-free Sarah Pugh and
while the regenerative effects of MSE
exosomes have been studied it's not
truly understood what components of the
exorcism mediate those effects
others have shown that MSE exosomes are
able to mediate angiogenic defects in a
dose-dependent manner so with increasing
concentrations of exosomes as you can
see here on the right hand side we can
increase the total length of two
segments
this is also visible and the images on
the right hand side where MSC exosomes
visibly promotes the formation of
branching into vex and this is shown in
the bottom image of the two point seven
point five micrograms per milliliter
exercise
and so while angiogenic effects were
reported for individual micro rna's the
mechanism vary and it's still unclear
which specific genes are targeted by the
excess normal MSC exosome and in order
to examine the mechanism of MSC exosomes
and promoting anger genesis we performed
on a sequencing unhu' Beck's treated
with MSC exercise and so the heat map on
the Left shows upregulated and
downregulated genes when helix were
treated with MSC exosome the graph on
the right illustrates the food
enrichment of Pro angiogenic and the
anti-angiogenic genes in cubic treated
with MSC exosomes
compared to non treated control cells so
the mRNA sequencing analysis revealed
that a number of jews promoting anger
Genesis were uprooted compared to non
treated salt and some genes were not
detected in any control samples that
were detected in the MSC exosome treated
sample and these include numerals and
your protein genes such as and Pt 1 and
P 2 4 and NP g o4 as well as other
important mediators of anger Genesis
Rogers F in type B receptor 2 and your
group Poland
2
additional several genes that are known
to inhibit angiogenesis or downregulated
into vex treated with MST exercise and
so those are shown in red and among
those dreams were unlocked five and
protein phosphatase 1a that were
significantly done regulated and those
were reported as negative regulators of
angiogenesis
MSCI systems also have an tyfa product
effects
and so what we did she is we stimulated
karaoke fiberglass with TGIF better to
stimulate collagen expression and we
then incubated the cells with increasing
concentrations of exosomes the
concentrations we use range from 0.12 8
micro gram per milliliter and as you can
see with increasing concentrations of
exosomes were actually able to reverse
the
collagen production and carry of
fiberglass
and so this is consistent with reports
showing that MSE exosomes have
antipsychotic effects when administered
in animal models with induced myocardial
infraction
so next we were interested to see if MSC
exosomes also mediates anti-apoptotic
effects and cardio myocyte
or if they can even use carry on my site
proliferation and so on the left upper
image we performed a tunnel si and as
you can see there with higher
concentrations of MSC exosomes
we were actually able to inhibit
apoptosis and neonatal cavity of
myocytes by about 10%
when we tested if MSE exosomes were able
to induce proliferation and cardio
myocyte we did not see any effects on
the increasing of proliferation of
carrion myocytes the no prefer Turkish
effects were observed now the question
is what is responsible for the
regenerative effects of exercise and
because microRNAs make up an important
component of exercise we were interested
to see if the effects could be explained
with the micro ionic composition and so
we performed micro RNA profiling with
the Nano string technology what we did
is we obtained reads of micro RNA back
and rank order than based on total
recalls and here we show the top 50
micro rna's
and what you can also see is that the
top 23 microRNAs accounted for 80% of
all of the accessible micronic content
and the remaining 128 micron is are
present at very low reads and made up a
very small percentage of the total reach
less than 0.7 percent and so we deem
them unlikely to have significant
biological effects compared to the more
abundant top 23 micro rna's and so they
were excluded for further analysis more
partly the average recount of the top 23
microRNAs we're at least 23 times more
abundant than the average recounts of
the remaining MSE microRNAs and so the
next question was that with so many
different micro rna's what effects do we
actually expect it is known that one
micronic can target hundreds of mRNAs
and so it can have hundreds of mRNA
targets and this is due to the fact that
you don't need 100% match based pairing
to observe my chronic effects so Mike
Ronnie can bind to mRNA just based on
their seed site as you can see in the
panel B they can bind in their central
dominant region shown in the panel C R
they can bind in the 3-prime
compensatory region shown in panel D
and so to predict the biological effects
of the top 23 microRNAs combined for use
by enzymatic analysis
and so what we did is we use murder to
predict the genes that are targeted by
these top 23 microRNAs and a total of
five thousand five hundred genes were
targeted then these genes target sets
were further another analyzed by pencil
to identify statistically
over-represented pathways and biological
processes and so as you can see here on
the left hand side on the left image the
majority of the genes substantially
contributed to specific processes
related to cardiovascular development
and your genesis and to formations there
were some pathways related to cell death
and growth and then pathways related to
fibrosis such as wind signaling PDGF and
tgf-beta
and the top micron is affecting the most
targets with respect to circulatory
system development and processes related
to vasculature
and to development where my 423 a creepy
micron is 4 to 4 micron a 1/4 for and
micro me 130 a
and to gain a better understanding of
how the genes and biological processes
through the related by the top 23
microRNAs relate to one another we
visualize the complex network with
cytoscape and so what you can see here
is that the micro RNA is the target
similar gene clusters are in close
proximity to one another for example
micron a $1.99 a 3p and micron in one
four five five P packets similar gene
clusters versus micron e29 a and micron
in 29 B those targets similar gene
classes as well but those are different
from the gene cluster cluster targeted
by the micron a $1.99 a and micron a 1 4
5 5 P
we then analyze the micron II target
genes with regard to the biological
pathways and again what you can see here
is that several of the pathways that we
actually shown just now with in vitro
experiments were predicted with a lot
bioinformatics analysis and these
include anger genesis integrant
signaling but also tgf-beta signaling
and PDGF that are signaling which is
responsible for extracellular matrix
depositions by increasing collagen and
fibronectin and by modulating fibrosis
some other pathways were predicted
however they were not statistically
significant
for example p53 and apoptotic pathway
and our in vitro experiments who were
able to show that MSE exosomes do have
some anti-apoptotic effect but the
effects were really weak
and so what we can say overall is that
we can actually confirm the biological
effects with our bioinformatics analysis
so there was high statistical
significance of pathways related to
anger Genesis and hypnosis such as PDF
and tgf-beta the MSC exosomes promote
anger Genesis and queue formation essay
using two vex and the NSC exosomes were
able to reduce fibrosis in our collagen
production essay using caveat
fibroblasts
there were other pathways that were
predicted but not statistically
significant and this include the p53
pathway and biological processes related
to growth dynamics of cardiovascular
system
so the next question we asked was can we
further improve the intrinsic
regenerative effects of MSE exosomes by
loading them with specific microRNAs and
from our network analysis we identified
micron a 130 a and micron a 199 as
potential candidates for mediating
angiogenic and anti-apoptotic effects
the micron a 130 is interesting because
it targets 99 genes related to anger
Genesis and it was the only abundant
microRNAs predicted to target ox a5 this
is an gene that inhibits angiogenesis
micron e19 9a has been shown to induce
up to half proliferative effects on
carry on my side and when we look at our
and silikal predictions it's also
targeted genes related to cell death
that were not targeted by any of the
other top 23 microarrays so that's why
we proceeded with micron a 1/3 a and 199
a and
what we did is we test a freeloader two
micron a one a nine a and micron a 130 a
into MSE exosomes so to do that we
electroporated the MSE cells with a
different types of microRNAs and watch
them to remove any unbound are
unincorporated micro armies and then
collected the exercise and we achieve
higher loading of micro rna's into
exosomes
with an increasing concentrations of the
micro rna's
we then went ahead and tested the
efficacy of the effect of these micro
Annie 130 a loaded exosomes on inducing
anger Genesis into vex and what you can
see here MSE exosomes enriched with high
doses of micro RNA 130 a Lisa shown in
the right panel left panel of the images
increased all anger Genesis and points
in a dose-dependent manner that was were
able to increase the total length but we
were able to increase the total number
of nodes the total number of junctions
and we were also able to increase to
significantly increase the mesh index
and so the non-treated are unmodified
exosomes did not score on the mesh index
indicating that a capillary lag network
of tubular structures only emerged with
specific enrichment with Mike Ronnie 130
a and so the mesh network is also very
nicely visualized in the images on the
right hand side from the upper image you
can see a huge egg cells that were not
treated so you don't see any tube
formation or any signs of meshes however
in the bottom image the huge egg cells
that were treated with Mike Ronnie 30 a
loaded exosomes showed a significant
increase in the number of branches and
in the number of meshes
and so the anger Genesis and using
effects of micro anyone or 30a have been
shown to obscure through the dumb
regulation of Hawks a5 and this is what
we have verified here when we determined
the expression level of Hawks a5
expression huge egg cells only the use
excels treated with the Mike Ronnie 280
of the Mike Ronnie 130 loaded exosomes
showed down-regulation of Hawks a5 and
that the down regulation is about 80
percent versus with unmodified exosomes
even at really really high concentration
there was only a negligible effect on
down regulation of Hawks a fire
we're then selected
on a $1.99 a for further analysis
because it has been shown to induce
proliferation and carry my site an
endpoint which we were unable to achieve
with just unmodified to MSE exosome
rather micron a1 online a loaded
exosomes significantly inhibited
apoptosis as shown in the tamil FA this
is shown in the right in the images on
the left hand side and the images on the
right hand side you can see that
neonatal carrier - sighs treated with
exosomes loaded with micro RNA $1.99 a
was actually able to increase carry on
my site proliferation and this and no
statistically significant memo
so in order to understand the mechanism
of action of MSC exosomes and micro RNA
109 a loaded exosomes in preventing
catamite sites apoptosis caramel sites
were actually treated with hydrogen
peroxide missus shown in the bottom
panel of the images
and so we then analyze the expression
levels of apoptotic markers such as p53
and s Kappa B bags and caspase-9 and X's
from treated and untreated carry on my
site and treatment of apoptosis induced
area - sites with unmodified exosomes
showed a trend towards bags type p53 and
NF kappa-b reduction the micro RNA one
line and a 3p loaded exosomes
significantly decreased Beck's
expression and mediated further
reductions of p53 and of Kappa B and
caspase-9
and so the increased potency of the
micro RNA one on line a loaded exosomes
is likely due to its ability to lower
the expression levels of multiple
inducing apoptosis and using genes as
shown here including caspase-9
9 which is an important initiator in the
apoptosis signaling cascade
so we were then interested to see how
the micro RNA content of exosomes
derived from other cells look like in
comparison to MSC pc3 and Tec exosome
and so again we performed micro RNA
profiling with the Nano string
technology and what we did is we rank
ordered the micron is based on total
read cost
and so what you can see here is that
generally speaking the my chronic
content of exosomes correlates pretty
well with the my chronic composition of
the parent cells so we have the Mike
Ronnie we of the heck cells
plotted against the Mike Ronnie recounts
of the heck exosomes and then we did the
same thing for the MSC so Mike Ronnie
recounts service we saw MSC exosome Mike
Ronnie recounts and then last but not
least we did other comparison for the
microRNAs found in PC three cells was
the micronics pond and the PCs exercise
and as you can see all of them show a
very nice correlation with a few
outliers if you look into which specific
micron is I actually enriched into
exosomes of specific from derived from
specific types of cells you can see that
some micron is a selectively packaged
into XSL and so each exosome have
different a unique Mike Ronnie profile
so the human embryonic kidney cells has
a different unique Mike Ronnie profile
compared to the mesenchymal stem cell
exosomes and compared to the prostate
cancer exercise
who have been interested to see how the
microRNAs of different excellence
correlate with one another and so as you
can see here the micron is between exes
on some different cells show really poor
correlation some of the microRNAs are
more abundant and MSC exosomes compared
to HEC exosomes this is the first image
and vice-versa and so each exercise two
seem to have their unique fingerprint
and the support the overall belief that
self-centered exosomes to modulate their
micro environment and this is also in
line with alarm purposes that it's very
important to characterize exosomes
before they are used as drug carriers
because depending on the subtlest
sources they can have a different micro
RNA composition and this in turn can
actually affect their biological
function
way of looking at the my chronic
composition of exosomes from the top 50
micron is from prostate cancer cells
embryonic kidney cells MSC exosomes they
are 21 microRNAs that the exosomes have
in color
MSE exosomes have 17 unique microRNAs
that are not present in HEC exosomes the
heck exosomes they have 15 unique micron
ease that are not present in pc3
exosomes or MSC exosomes
and again pc3 exosomes have 11 unique
micron ease that cannot be found in MSC
exosomes
our HEC exercise
and so as a summary I can say that MSC
exosomes have regenerative effects and
this can impart being explained by their
micro ionic composition and so we were
able to predict the biological processes
and pathways using by informatics
analysis we were also able to further
improve on the intrinsic regenerative
effects of MSC exosomes by loading them
with specific micro rna's and in this
case it was Mike Romney won 3-0 and
micron a $1.99 a and so those micron is
further increase the effects of the MSE
exosomes on anger genesis they further
significantly increase the
anti-apoptotic effect and they also
increase the effects on Calumet I'd
collaboration and so in general we can
also say that exosomes derived from
different cells display unique micron in
composition and this has very important
implications for their biological
function their side effects when used
for treating specific diseases but also
for therapeutic applications
so I would like to thank you for your
attention most of the work was done by
Scott Ferguson originally one and
Christine Lee and I would like to thank
the NIH and the NSF for funding and with
that I'm happy to take any questions
that you have
Thank You dr. muin for that informative
presentation we will now start the live
Q&A portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question
drop-down box located on the far left to
your presentation window type your
question into the box that appears on
your screen and click the send button
once there as many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is you have shoma
exosomes
derived from different cellular sources
so to speak biological activities based
on that which exosomes should be used as
drug carriers and for what applications
thank you I like this I think this is a
very important question our data
indicates that my attention needs to be
paid to the exosomes
chosen as drug carriers and so it's
really important that they are
characterized prior to use clearly as we
have shown here MSE exosomes are ideal
for tissue regeneration also for
regeneration of high product and
ischemic tissue however they are a lot
of phenotypic effect that could be
negative in one application that may be
beneficial in another and so in our
reasonably published paper where we also
did micro RNA profiling using the Nano
string platform we show that PC 3 and
HEC exosomes
will show effects that could potentially
promote adverse clinical effects and
certain conditions so they could promote
tumor growth to undesired macrophage
polarization by promoting salma invasion
and this is was a little bit surprising
to see because HEC exosomes is a widely
used cellular sauce for exosomes and and
also use as drug carriers so I think we
really need to pay attention to the
intrinsic biological effects of exercise
in general
and it looks like we have time for one
more question as you mentioned exosomes
contain various components including
different types of lipids our EXO soma
lipids inner or do they also exert
biological activity yes so in the study
we have mainly focused on the micro
ionic composition of exosomes but we
know that exosomes also consists of
other components and one of those
components our look at and so there are
a lot of studies are results that now
indicate that lipids not only surface
piyo vesicles but are also biologically
active for example ceramide which are
present at low concentrations and
exercise they can actually have poor
apoptotic effects and so ceramide
enriched exosomes i've been shown to
induce astrocytes apoptosis and so this
could potentially contribute to the
progression of Alzheimer's diseases and
there are other types of lipids that are
present in exosomes that actually can
affect play a role in the progression of
our diseases and so these studies trying
to suggest that the effects of exosomes
are not only mediated by the protein and
nucleic acid content but also that the
exosome of lipids can significantly
modulate that by activity
I would like to once once again thank
dr. neuen for her presentation I would
also like to thank ministering
technologies for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to let everyone know that
today's webcast will be available for
on-demand viewing through August of 2018
you will receive an email from Labyrinth
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share
that announcement with your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
that's all for now
thank you for joining us and we hope to
see you again soon goodbye